Der forschungsreaktor wendelstein 7-x in greifswald hat. Einen. Neuen weltrekord aufgestellt es wurde. Ein fusionsprodukt erzeugt das
So energiereich war wie keine zuvor das heißt dass die kombination aus jungen
Temperatur plasma dichte und energie einschluss zeit die höchste je erzeugte war oder umgangssprachlich
Noch, nie war die kombination der drei eigenschaften des plasmas aus temperatur dichte und dauer in einen stellarator
Reaktor so hoch wie der rekord erreicht werden. Konnte und wie es jetzt weitergeht in kriegs. Und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ein kraftwerk das durch eine kernfusion unmengen an energie produzieren das könnte die lösung aller energieprobleme
Dieser erde sein das große vorbild die sonne der traum von forschungsteams weltweit das kann von uns
Experiment wendelstein 7-x in greifswald ist ein
Heißer, kandidat, um neue spannende erkenntnisse dazu. Zu liefern nach umbauarbeiten wurde jetzt
Ein neuer rekord aufgestellt wendelstein simics ist ein versuchsreaktor der den
Bau eines funktionierenden und eben energie liefernden stellarator reaktors ermöglichen soll und es scheint als
Läuft hier alles wirklich nach plan. Dabei ist die sonne das natürliche vorbild für die kernfusion
hierbei verschmelzen die atomkerne von wasserstoff unter sehr hohem druck, und hoher temperatur
miteinander dabei entsteht helium und
Riesige mengen an energie werden freigesetzt deswegen wird die kernfusion arbeitet auch als die neue primäre energiequelle
gehandelt und könnte tatsächlich
co2 frei
Erneuerbare energien ergänzen und sie ist dabei vor allem viel ungefährlicher als die
Aktuelle atom spaltung in kernkraftwerken hier kann es zu einer super gefährlichen kettenreaktion
kommen einem super-gau der unmengen an radioaktiver strahlung freisetzt bei einem fusionsreaktor
Kommt die reaktion bei einem unfall dagegen direkt zum erliegen und die radioaktiven stoffe die entstehen besitzen eine halbwertszeit von
Jahrzehnten, und nicht von jahrmillionen die kernfusion. Wäre ein riesenfortschritt dabei ist der cellerar tor reaktor etwas anders
Konstruiert als der zuckermarkt typ, der jetzt mit dem etat in frankreich. Gebaut wird bei beiden typen muss
Ein magnetfeld das fusions plasma in einem jahr in einem ring halten da es millionen grad
Heiß darf es nicht mit den. Wänden des reaktors in berührung. Kommen beim töpfermarkt wird dazu
Im plasma, ein strom induziert. Und beim steyrer radtour wird das magnetfeld. Komplett von außen erzeugt so muss der reaktor in allerdings
Kompliziert verdrillt werden was die. Konstruktion ungleich schwieriger macht bei wendelstein. 7-x ist das gelungen
Und so sind dort alle experimente auch bisher gelungen und jetzt wurde im unterschied zur ersten
experimentieren runde 2000 15 16 das plasma gefäß von wendelstein 7-x mit einer
Innenverkleidung ausgerüstet kacheln aus graphit bedecken jetzt die gefäßwände
Und machen höhere temperatur und längere plasma entladungen möglich mit diesen sogenannten die wärter lässt sich darüber
hinaus die reinheit und dichte des plasmas regeln zitat die ersten erfahrungen mit dem
neuen wandelementen sind ausgesprochen positiv
Sagt thomas an pedersen leiter des projektes waren am ende der ersten kampagne
puls dauern von sechs sekunden zu erreichen sind nun bis zu
26 sekunden lange platzenden möglich. Dabei. Konnten bis zu 75. Megajoule
Heizenergie in das plasma eingespeist werden 18 mal mehr als in der ersten betriebs runde
Ohne die wörter auch die heizleistung. Konnte erhöht werden eine voraussetzung für eine hohe plasma dichte auf diese
Weise wurde ein neuer weltrekord wert für das sogenannte
fusionsprodukt erreicht dieses produkt aus ionen temperatur plasma dichte und energie
Ein schlusszeit das gibt an wie nah man den reaktor werten für ein brennendes plasma kommt bei rund 40 millionen grad
Temperatur und einer dichte von 0,8 mal 10, hoch 20 teilchen pro kubikmeter hat wendelstein
7-x
ein fusionsprodukt von gut 6 x 10 auf
26 grad mal sekunde pro kubikmeter erreicht weltweiter stelle rato rekord hammer zitat
Dies ist ein für die größe der maschine ausgezeichneter wert der zudem unter realistischen bedingungen
das heißt bei hoher temperatur
Der. Plasmonen erreicht wurde so sagt peters die erzielte energie einschluss zeit, ein maß für die
Güte der wärmeisolation des magnetisch, eingeschlossenen placements deutet mit beachtlichen 200 millisekunden darauf
hin dass die wendelstein 7-x
Zugrundeliegende rechnerische optimierung greift zitat das stimmt. Und für die weitere arbeit optimistisch jetzt wird weiter
Experimentiert. Und im herbst werden. Dann neue kacheln. Eingebaut die jetzigen. Graffitis die werthers werden durch
Kohlenstofffaserverstärkte kohlenstoff elemente ersetzt die zusätzlich wasser gekühlt sind sie sollen bis zu 30 minuten lange entladungen
Die ich machen in denen überprüft werden kann ob wendelstein 7-x seine optimierungs ziele auch dauerhaft erfüllt wir halten. Euch natürlich auf dem laufenden
Wenn, ihr keine videos zu der entwicklung in diesen bereichen zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Dann, umgeht er die kaputte abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich und garantiert einfach hier drauf kriegen, und am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um
Social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür ihr klicken aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken kernfusion vor dem durchbruch. Bis. Dann
bleibt dran